foreign
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios this is the
Ramsey show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm George Campbell joined
today by best-selling author and fellow
Ramsey personality Christina Ellis and
we are taking your calls about life
money budgeting debt credit scores
credit cards how to get out of them what
to do instead we are here for you
America the number to call is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five you know Christine I got a
lot of questions via Instagram and
they're usually like it starts like hey
I got a question and a 17 paragraph So I
want to let all of those people know
call into the show because it's really
hard it's like having a full-on
conversation via text it's just takes
too long so call us up instead and we
can help you that way it's a good call
yes and Gia has done that we appreciate
that in Lincoln Nebraska starting us off
welcome to the show Gia
thanks so much guys how can we help
today
so my husband and I are trying to find
out we are 25 and 30 years old we don't
have any debt besides our house we have
about thirty thousand seven hundred
dollars less
um and currently in the bank we have
somewhere around 28 to 29 000 dollars
um in savings all combined
um all of that's just liquid cash so
we're trying to decide after our
paychecks next month
um we would have more than the 30
like we would have enough to pay off our
house so we're trying to decide should
we just go ahead and pay it off and be
done and basically just put that extra
money that we've been putting towards
our house basically just paying
ourselves back and replenishing that
savings or should we just keep plugging
away on the current plan that we have is
the 30 000 that you have in the bank is
that your emergency fund or is that
money separate from your emergency fund
that is emergency fund included so we
have
um a thousand dollar emergency fund and
then we have 18 000 for the three to six
month
okay so my short answer is no and the
longer answer is no and here's why
Murphy is going to be knocking at your
door as soon as you pay that house off
and the hvac's going to go out and then
you're going to be broke and have to go
into debt to fix it and so I don't like
the idea of you guys draining your
emergency fund in order to pay the house
off now I know where it's coming from
you guys are so excited and you see the
numbers and you go oh my gosh you see
the light at the end of the tunnel is
that what you're feeling
um it's a little bit of that and it's
also just a little bit like I looked at
the insurance like not the insurance the
interest that we're paying every month
on the house and I'm like well we could
just knock it off and then instead of
putting that like the extra money that
we've been putting towards the house and
all of that we basically would give
ourselves like a 2300 pay raise in a
sense because instead of that extra
twenty three hundred dollars
just going to the principal every month
um it would just go back in our bank
account without like without the without
the interest payment on top of that well
I love that you're you're seeing that
interest and you're going man I want to
knock that out because a lot of people
you know they go Ah that's not a whole
lot like let's just keep pushing off the
mortgage but the fact that you're seeing
that and going nah we want to pay this
off that is great motivation but as
somebody who has had an HVAC and a
transmission go out in the same month I
would definitely want to keep that
emergency fund because like George said
Murphy will hit when you least expect
him and if you only have that thousand
dollars in your emergency fund that's
great when you're in baby step two but
when you can have that flexibility to
have that emergency fund for those type
of major issues it's definitely a lot
more comforting and keeps you a lot
safer yeah Gia are you both working
outside of the home
is there two incomes yes and are they
stable we have a double
yes okay they are both stable I'm a
registered nurse and then my husband
works for a furniture company and then
actually within the next so next year
starting in September we're looking to
actually send him back for HVAC and
plumbing awesome to go back to school
well we can split the difference here
what you could do is go down to a
three-month level emergency fund and use
the rest to pay off the house sooner
but that is as low as I would go since
you both have stable incomes so I would
do the math on that okay what's three
months of expenses to cover everything
that we have in our budget and
whatever's left we can use that plus our
future income and savings to pay off the
house in the next few months instead of
you know six months or whatever it would
have been so how much faster would that
get you guys completely debt free
um if you went down to three months
well each year so that would be 18 000
added so I'd probably take us like the
next we would be debt free color in the
next
six months but my job I'm actually going
from part-time to full time and I'm not
100 sure what like my paychecks are
gonna be like completely because I you
know get paid hourly and not salary so
I'm probably more like four or five so
I'll be going
yeah so probably something more like
that I just don't know for sure I
haven't uh been able to get the numbers
concrete yet because I haven't gotten
that first paycheck yet yeah well just
listen to that you're 25 and 30 years
old and in four months you have a fully
paid for house so you guys are just so
driven and I love that but sometimes
with people who are driven like
Christine and I are the same way and
we're like we just want to see it gone
we'll do whatever it takes that can
cause us to make some poor decisions
along the way and so just have your eye
on the prize four or five months from
now that mortgage is going to be gone
and we're still going to have a fully
funded emergency fund and have that
financial piece
that's good stuff that's gonna feel so
good and I hope you all come to
Nashville and see us I want to hear you
on this stage I'm excited to hear more
about your journey because the way
you're motivated the way you all have
fought through this and the fact that
you only have 30 000 left and you're 25
and 30. that's so exciting so I want to
hear more about this story and how you
got there because yes that's just
awesome and Christina we've been seeing
an awesome Trend where we have people in
their 20s and early 30s doing debt-free
screams saying we pay it off our house
yes and a lot of those are what we call
Financial Peace babies meaning their
parents went through financial peace and
they raised their kids in such a way to
give them good money principles and they
latch onto this stuff so much earlier
and so we see people graduating college
debt free I hear so many people that
come visit us on the stage and they
whisper Yeah we actually sent all four
kids to college debt free because of you
guys and we're like we did nothing yeah
or their kids who went through
foundations our personal finance
curriculum for high school students I
see a lot of students who you know they
went through it in high school they
learned all the things that we wished we
would have learned in high school you
know when I talk to adults they're
constantly like why didn't we learn
about basic budgeting when we were in
high school well these kids are doing
that and then they're getting out of
high school and they're starting out the
right way they're getting that debt for
your degree and they're immediately
putting together an emergency fund and
paying off houses at like 21 and 22
which is it's incredible and we also
hear people who are in their 40s 50s 60s
going gosh I wish I knew this stuff 20
30 years ago and the Beautiful Thing is
parents you can give that to your
children and it is your responsibility
to teach them these money principles
because guess what culture is not social
media is not and what happens is they
end up going hundreds of thousands of
dollars into debt because we've taught
these kids from a young age get good
grades so you can go to this college of
your dreams no matter the cost and we by
the way we haven't saved a penny for it
because we're broke as parents and then
they walk out of college with hundreds
of thousands in debt going we were lied
to you guys said this was the path to
the best life yeah and here we are
feeling screwed it's painful to see that
but we see that every day and so even if
if you're not a parent if you're just a
mentor if you're somebody in a church
who works with young people have those
money conversations I know they can be
kind of awkward but invest in young
people and have those have it early and
often and make them listen to the Ramsay
show at 13 and they will hate you now
and they will love you later and that's
parenting isn't it hey more of your
calls coming up give us a call Triple
eight eight two five five two two five
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
Campbell joined by Christina Ellis today
this is the Ramsay show give us a call
Triple eight eight two five five two two
five Cody joins us up next in Denver
Cody welcome to the Ramsay show
hey George and Christina thank you for
taking my call appreciate it absolutely
how can we help
HSA
and I recently discovered that the one
that my employer provides uh it comes
with the option of investing it in uh
various funds just like a retirement of
401k
um included in those are mutual funds
and I was just wondering would that be
wise to do or should I just treat the
HSA as a savings account it is
absolutely wise to do I love that now it
depends on where you're at in your
financial Journey so do you know the
baby steps where you where are you at in
that do you have Dad
I guess I'm on baby step seven oh
awesome you gotta pay for a house
I do
last week that's awesome man how old are
you
32. and what's your house worth
uh 350 400. you are a rock star man way
to go
so thank you as far as the HSA yes so
once you're past a certain threshold in
that account for ours here at Ramsey I
have an HSA with the high deductible
health care plan so my threshold is once
you have over a thousand dollars you can
invest money beyond that and so do you
have that already in your HSA how much
is in there yeah there's uh just over a
thousand and I think a thousand is the
threshold as well in that plan perfect
yes you can go in there and select
Investments if you need help with that
of course you can reach out to a
smartvestor pro and depending on what's
in there you can match what you're
investing in your 401k and do those same
mutual funds and just make sure they're
Diversified across the four types that
we teach
okay so use the same exact investing
principles yes and it's something Dave
Ramsey does himself is he invests in his
HSA but he uses his own money to cover
his health expenses and just lets that
money grow
and so it becomes a second kind of
retirement and investing vehicle that
you can use later in life because as we
know your health expenses go way up
later in life
sounds great well thank you very much
yeah and you're just a rock star I love
that are you coming in to do your debt
free scream
I would love to but I actually just
moved away from uh Tennessee so that I
could kind of get into this situation
well hey we are cheering you on from
here that's amazing yes way to go Cody
Christina this is only perpetuating this
beautiful theme of young people doing
amazing things with money right 32 paid
off house that is incredible living the
dream Cody yeah love to see that and the
HSA is it's a great point for all of our
listeners out there that it is a great
investment vehicle so not only can you
put in money tax-free it grows tax-free
you can withdraw a tax-free for
qualified medical expenses but there's
also the investment side of it too and I
love the strategy you were saying with
Dave where he will pay for the expenses
separately to let that build up this is
my first year at Ramsey and getting to
do the HSA which that's such a great
strategy because I've had I've looked at
it and been like man I want this to pile
up so that when I'm older it's a lot
bigger of an investment but that's a
great strategy I love that it's
something you can do once you get to
that baby step seven side you can really
go Hog Wild otherwise it's good to have
up to your deductible in the HSA your
out-of-pocket maximum yep so that way
you have if it's 7 500 bucks it's good
to have that level in there once you're
past you know your baby step three and
you want to start really covering your
family and protecting yourselves that's
a great thing to do so look into that I
know it's not fun digging into your like
health insurance fine print but it's
super helpful to know that you're
covered yeah it is super helpful and it
just it's good to just be on top of it
it's been interesting I was sick
recently and having a high deductible
plan it really makes you evaluate your
expenses a lot more it makes you go hmm
do I want that extra test do I want the
extra thing but we had a call just the
other day with someone going I got
billed for all these tests and so I
asked for an itemized and now he's
fighting it so always make sure you know
the healthcare services you're getting
and verify them because when you ask for
the itemized Bill all of a sudden it's a
lot lower because they went oh gosh this
person is paying attention to the 90
Advil we gave them right well in in
medical debt that's one of the top debts
in America so it is important to be
really on top of what you're being
charged for and being proactive and
looking at those line items because a
lot of times they do just assume you're
gonna pay for everything or if you have
a really great insurance plan maybe they
do pay for everything but if you're
somebody with an HS sa with a high
deductible plan you really want to pay
attention to those line items oh yeah
and medical debt is one of the most
frustrating because it's the only debt
you don't really choose to go in right
there's not like a glamorous cool thing
you get to hold at the end of it yes so
I have a lot more empathy for that that
side and the good thing is a lot of the
times you can negotiate medical bills if
they've been sitting out for a while
especially if they're in collections
which I don't recommend you send them to
collections just negotiate them pay them
but you can also negotiate with billing
and get on payment plans if you're
struggling and so there's a lot of
financial aid in that Healthcare space
but it is a screwed up system we can all
agree on that well and it's important
too just to have an advocate with you
when you are going through something
major in medical you're overwhelmed like
that's a lot and when you're feeling
like your health is struggling the last
thing you're really thinking about is
how much am I going to be charged for
this or I got to call billing and be on
a phone tree for the next 28 minutes
right exactly so if you're going through
something it is really helpful to have
somebody in your corner who's willing to
Advocate to have those conversations and
kind of stay on top of the money side of
things so you don't get through that
major health episode and go oh man what
is all this I didn't see it coming and
you're paying for it for months and
months all right let's go back to the
phones John joins us in Anaheim
California John welcome to the show
how's it going great how are you
pretty good
um so I'm kind of like confused
um in the situation I'm in so I'm gonna
go back six months uh six months ago me
and my girlfriend are living at my
parents house
and the plan is to stay there and start
a family there since my parents are in
their late 60s my mom doesn't work she
gets gets Social Security
and my dad doesn't work because he's
disabled So the plan is is for us to
start a life there and help out that and
in case you need help for anything uh
four months ago my father actually
passed away oh I'm sorry now yeah thank
you well I'm kind of getting ahead of
myself so I'm leaving there with my
parents I have a brother and a sister
they both live outside of the city
and in the future the plan is is for us
three to split the house like an
inheritance right so right now my father
passed away my mom cannot afford the
mortgage so I'm gonna take over the
mortgage
so I want to know what's the best way I
guess to handle things in the end to be
fair which I guess me because I'm taking
over the mortgage and also fair to my
brother and sisters since
then we're also going to get that
inheritance
what's left on the mortgage
250
um what's your relationship like with
your brother and sister
is it pretty it's a very it's a great
relationship like that's why
um I want something to be fair you know
because in the way I was like you know
while we're thinking well
what if in the end you guys just
play with the houses where like what you
need to pay right now
like and say well what the houses work
at the end you guys I guess you give
them the money that's worth right now
or I was thinking what if
at the end is like doing up selling it
let's say in 40 years I take 50 and then
they split the other 50 percent
what is the house worth right now
the house right now is worth I believe
850 000. okay so there's about 600 in
equity if you owe 250.
right so here's one way to do it and
this all involves a conversation and
everyone agreeing but what you could do
is say hey there's 250 left in the
mortgage so when we do sell this thing
and it becomes all of ours you would owe
your portion of that 250.
so you'd subtract that from whatever the
profits of the home were
does that make sense
yes so 250 divided you said there's two
other siblings
right right so it's uh three of us okay
so let's say the home you you sell the
home years from now and it's worth
900.
right and you split it three ways that
would be 300 each if it's paid for right
right but since you paid that mortgage
over those years and hopefully paid it
off early they would subtract 83 because
that's their portion of the mortgage
that was left
okay one option and you may want to get
with an estate attorney just to talk
this through to make sure everything is
clear because it can get a little bit
sticky especially in the future when
your mom does pass you just want to make
sure that everything is really clearly
lined out especially if you're paying
for that mortgage for the next several
years you just want to make sure that
everything is on paper even though it's
family even though no handshake
agreements here right because you don't
want these to turn into broken
relationships because of this
inheritance which we see all too often
so have the conversation do what's fair
that you all agree on and deal with that
when the time comes but talk about it
now and have a game plan thanks so much
for calling in this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
well it is no secret that we love
talking money around here but we know
not everyone feels that way and that's
why Rachel Cruz and I started thinking
about what it would be like to talk
money for those who'd rather just have
some fun so last week we launched a new
Ramsay podcast called smart money happy
hour where Rachel and I dig into the
stuff you and your friends would talk
about at your weekly happy hour with a
little bit of a money slant so we're
talking pop culture what's going on in
the world and how to afford a life you
love this is fun casual money advice
that will make you feel less stressed
and More in control of your money plus
there's some Hilarious Moments there
Christina if you've listened I don't I
don't know what you have but we've been
having a great time and people have been
telling me they are talking to us like
in the car or their list they're talking
to us they're engaging in the
conversation which makes me feel real
good and there's always a takeaway you
learn something in there and so it's
been a lot of fun to see the feedback
we've been hanging out in the top 20 of
all podcasts for a week strong
impressive and I love it because it's
just that is genuinely who y'all are
like it is really like having had a
happy hour with y'all it is like who you
are yeah in real life like I could see
people talking in the car to y'all
because that's just hanging out it's our
most authentic self yep and so we we
sometimes have a mocktail or a cocktail
in hand and just to create a casual
environment and we've got three episodes
one j a new one just released today so
we started with is convenience culture
worth being broke hitting all the trends
out there with Amazon and Google and we
then went into the TV network to
brainwashed us all spoiler alert it's
HGTV and just today we released how rich
is the royal family and how to build
your financial Empire oh this was a
fascinating one we dig into exactly what
their estate is made up of what kind of
income it creates for them how they have
passed this all on what's going on with
the will I mean it is mind-blowing stuff
oh man regardless of how you feel about
the royal family which I didn't know
much about them Rachel follows it you
know like it's a reality show I'm with
her it's like Keeping Up with the
Kardashians and then keeping up with the
royal family so I learned a lot and we
also talk about how to leave your own
legacy for your family how to build
wealth what net worth really means and
so there's some really cool takeaways in
there and uh the best part is hearing
Rachel's British accent oh which man I
think I said in the podcast was
offensive to all people groups oh but it
got better we did some training behind
the scenes and so I think we included
that at the end for your listening
pleasure
um so thank you all so much for the
feedback so far you can go subscribe
follow smart money happy hour wherever
you listen to podcasts and it's also on
YouTube just the audio we'll have video
a lot of people have been asking for
that we've posted some clips to social
media but videos coming for season two I
loved your clip when uh when Rachel said
she had a what was it a Droid a Droid
your face was priceless and the Android
users they're like bots in the comments
they're so angry at me for being an
apple listen I worked at the Apple Store
and one guy even said he has a haircut
like an apple guy I was like I didn't
know we had certain haircuts whoa I
don't know I guess we're all just like
that hipster we take care of ourselves
you know we shower daily sorry Droid
users
get it get on it but uh we have a good
time uh even if we rib each other on
that show so don't miss out every
Thursday we've got a new episode for you
the next one is on Disney and Disney
adults and Disney trauma and are they
pricing out the middle class it is we're
just stepping stepping on eggshells here
walking on them because there's a lot of
Disney fans out there yeah and I might
ruffle some fret some feathers in that
episode there's a lot of Disney fans in
this building yes there was one in the
room and she shared her her thoughts as
well so hey and just to brag on you guys
George it's number one in apple business
charts one podcast it's number 19
overall for all podcasts on Apple it's
number one in Spotify business so you
guys are crazy that's amazing well thank
you producer James for pulling the
numbers just so people don't think I'm
making this up and it's no credit to me
uh the team has done an amazing job with
this from the design to the recording to
the editing to the marketing it's been
so fun to work with our incredible team
of talented folks and me and Rachel just
you know we yak and they put it out
there so go check it out let me know
what you think good or bad because I
know you're going to do it anyways so
might as well encourage it so there you
go smart money happy hour go check it
out all right open phones this hour
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Mark joins us up next in
Springfield Missouri Mark welcome to the
Ramsay show
hey how you doing George and Christina
doing great how can we help all right
sir well first off I want to say uh
grown-ups use Androids and little kids
use iPhones
let me tell you why Mark before we get
into your question it's because Apple
makes an intuitive device that even
children can use and if to use a Droid
you have to be a software engineer to
figure that thing out
so there you go that's my hot take all
right but anyway my question uh today is
I started my own business about 17
months ago and I'm in baby step two
and I was wondering if I'm a a veteran
retired military and I was wondering if
I should use my GI Bill to go back to
school for like business administration
or something like that to to get some
extra income because as you know with
the GI bill I will get paid to go to
school so I was wondering if I should do
that to get extra income to help with
baby step two or if I should just focus
on building my business what kind of
business do you have right now uh pet
Waste Management I'm a pooper scooper oh
how's it going are you making good money
doing this uh yeah right now I'm making
about 1200 a week before taxes way to go
and is this like in your neighborhood
how have you been marketing this thing
uh well I'm in the entire Springfield
metropolitan area so there's uh all of
all of Springfield Missouri and then
like five other cities that are fairly
decent sized you know around 10 000 or
more people way to go man and thank you
for your sacrifice as well yeah you're a
hero hey if you go back to school how
much do you anticipate it'll increase
your income
um I think I'm not positive but I I
think it'll be about a thousand dollars
a month
extra a month and that's strictly
through they pay like a housing
allowance thing okay
um and that's okay so the housing
allowance is what you're counting on do
you want to go back to school is that
something you're Desiring outside of the
financial aspect not really I mean I I
was the way the way I am right now is I
know how to do my job but it's getting
more business oriented and I'm not sure
how to handle all of that I'm doing my
best but I'm not great at it
you what are you solo or do you have a
team okay would you are you looking to
expand
uh eventually yeah okay you have not
hired a few people so you can have them
in different areas and not have it all
be on you
yes well a thousand dollars a month for
the GI bill I mean I think you can make
another thousand dollars a month in your
business like George said expand you
could bring on someone who is good at
business who could help you with some of
the administrative part of it and you
could focus more on growing and doing
what you do so that's kind of one side
of things and then you could also go
back to school if that's something you
really desire of course it's great to
gain business skills but I would want
you to do it because you really want to
do it and you want to gain those skills
versus just getting an extra thousand
dollars a month
yeah that's well what I was looking at
was you know I'd get the extra thousand
and I'd get the business you know it
like
knowledge I guess and you know it's you
know school's never been my cup of tea
but if it's something that I could do to
help you know my business and help me
through baby step two then you know I'd
be willing to do it type thing yeah how
long is it going to take you to get this
business degree are you looking at a
four-year program
yeah it was I I was looking at on uh uh
one of the online universities and it
was a four-year program and do you think
you can maintain your business currently
at 1200 a week while going to school
uh absolutely where I'm at right now I'm
I'm not even working a full week yet so
okay wow that's pretty awesome so you
think you can still keep growing your
business and expanding and making that
money while going to school
yeah because I'm working about 28 hours
a week right now okay this is impressive
yeah you've built a cool business here
that is it seems sustainable especially
if you get a team around you to scale
this thing to where you can make even
more and while working even less yeah
and I mean if you have the motivation
right now to go back to school and it's
paid for and you think you can maintain
the business at the same time I mean I
don't see any loss in that yeah and this
extra thousand dollars is it does it
have to be any kind of qualified
expenses or are they just writing you a
check every month they just give you a
check every month wow you have to go you
have to go to school for a certain
amount of time like like you know
certain amount of hours each yeah yeah
full time I would do it man I mean I
would do it but I'd also want you to
really be invested in the education and
not just for the paycheck so you know
Search Your Heart there and if it feels
right go for it either way you're
succeeding and I'm proud of you so thank
you for your service and congrats on the
business who knew past weight management
hey somebody's got to do it awesome just
like dirty jobs with Mike Rowe yeah with
our friend uh our friend on the line
here thank you so much for the call Mark
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
Campbell she's Christina Ellis this is
the Ramsey show our question of the day
comes from blinds.com they're 100
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
miss measure or pick the wrong color
they will remake your blinds for free
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use promo code
Ramsay to get the best deal
today's question comes from Rhonda in
Ohio I was wondering how you feel about
applying for FAFSA is it worth the time
if you think your income is too much and
you won't take out student loans I
absolutely think that you should apply
for the FAFSA the fact that you're even
asking this questions means that your
income is probably on the line where
it's close enough that you likely could
qualify and it's worth the shot of at
least checking to see there are no
income limits so you can apply for the
FAFSA no matter who you are and it
literally takes less than an hour I
think a lot of people feel really
intimidated by it they think that it's
going to be you know hours and hours and
hours of work but it's they continually
simplify it so it's getting a lot easier
to do and it's worth checking plus even
if you don't get a lot of financial aid
you don't get a lot of need-based Aid at
your school some scholarships actually
require the FAFSA even if you have a
high income so for example the Tennessee
promise they require you to submit the
FAFSA it's a two-year scholarship for
students in Tennessee and everybody is
eligible for the tenancy promise with
certain certain parameters but
financially everybody's eligible but you
still have to fill out the FAFSA so you
might as well apply plus the sooner you
apply to when the opens up the more
likely you're going to receive Aid so
you don't want to wait until April and
go oh man I just found a scholarship
that requires me to apply for the FAFSA
then you apply then and realize oh wow I
could have had so much Aid if I would
have applied back in October so give it
a shot it doesn't take a lot of time
plus they're making some changes on it
in the 24 25 school year that'll make it
even quicker you're going to be able to
sync with the IRS website and just
transfer your tax information over even
quicker than what they allow right now
right now you have to go out into a data
retrieval tool and then come back soon
it's just going to be synced together
which is pretty awesome makes it just a
lot easier and less intimidating for
people wow the government is like a
Baptist Church they eventually get get
on the trends it just takes them a
little longer you know that's great well
look at it this way if it takes an hour
to fill out the FAFSA then you make a
hundred dollars in scholarships even
that's a hundred dollars an hour you
just made right so don't poo poo this
don't put it aside I'm reading a stat
here 57 of high school graduates from
the class of 21 the FAFSA so those that
did not they missed out on this 3.75
billion dollars in Pell Grants went
unclaimed in 21. ouch well Anthony just
sitting out there money just sitting out
there and some people might say oh my
family didn't qualify for a lot of need
we only got a thousand bucks and
financial need and it's like that's a
thousand dollars for one hour of work so
yeah this is big and I remember when we
did this uh we were gifted so graciously
inside of the FAFSA with loans so do not
fall for this part of this is they say
hey part of this financial aid package
is a bunch of these unsubsidized loans
subsidized loans Plus Loans if it has
the word loan on it it's not a gift you
have to pay that back so I'm only taking
the financial aid that is actually free
money 100 that's such an important point
I was actually just at a college
counselor's conference last week and
they were saying that around 50 of
families couldn't identify the
difference between a loan and gifted in
the financial aid package when they were
reading the award letters and it's like
that yeah that's a lot of people looking
at those loans and thinking oh I got
gifted money and it's not free money so
it is important to be able to to
distinguish the difference and that's
part of the reason I had thirty six
thousand dollars of student loan debt
ouch when I graduated and I didn't
really understand at 18 I just thought
my parents are loaded because they're
just going yeah well we got this don't
worry about it buddy and I realized oh
they just like co-signed a bunch of
loans for me yeah I gotta pay these back
now and so you are the opposite side of
that getting half a million dollars in
scholarships because you were very
intentional and strategic and had the
conversation early with your mom and so
this is what to do and what not to do
with me Christina on the air today but
man I have so many friends in that
situation that's why I wanted to dive
into this space is because I've had so
many friends that went you know I had
responsible adults telling me it's okay
to take out fifty thousand dollars in
loans or a hundred thousand dollars in
loans why didn't somebody stop me and
say hey there's a different way you
don't have to go into debt this is what
it will mean in the law long run and so
I just think it's so important to have
those conversations and I'm so
passionate about this space because we
have to create this conversation with
young people and help them avoid it yes
and it starts with you parents and an
easy way to do this because I know it's
awkward to talk to your kids about this
because you have your own shame and
baggage when it comes to your money
mistakes and so you feel uncomfortable
talking to your kid about this a really
easy way to start the conversation is to
just sit down with them and watch
borrowed future this is our feature film
documentary it's 88 minutes long it's
entertaining so if you're a teenager you
are going to be hooked and your eyes are
going to be like popping out of your
head going wait what now I had no idea
Sallie Mae was in it with the government
and this is how this thing got out of
control and I had no idea that this is
how much people actually make when they
get out of college versus how much loans
they have so it's a great way to spark a
conversation yeah it's such a good way
it's it's one thing to like just talk at
kids and say numbers and they're like
boring but to have like a visual to see
a doctor in tears in the documentary
because you know he talked
it's worth watching just for the
orthodontist wow so it's it's inspiring
it's heartbreaking Christina's story is
woven in there so go to Borrowed
future.com you can watch it uh this
weekend with the kiddos yeah and maybe
you incentivize them say hey we'll go to
your favorite restaurant if you're
willing to watch this with me because I
know as a teenager like what are you
doing Mom I don't want to watch anything
you want to watch you're lame but that's
it's good stuff all right Logan joins us
up next in Asheville Logan welcome to
the show
hey guys thanks for connecting with me
today sure what's up
yeah so quick question for you so I'm in
baby step two uh should be done by the
end of the year all that's left is
student loans and so I'm a hustler by
Nature so I've got a full-time day job I
work in full-time Ministry but I'm also
renting my vehicle out on Toro which is
basically Airbnb for your car
um and so with that my car has been just
rented out all the time and so I had a
friend sell me a really old Forerunner
that I really like personally I like
driving that more and so I'm considering
now selling the vehicle that I have put
on Toro now keep in mind all of these
cars are paid off uh I don't owe
anything on them but I just feel like
right now I could probably get more so
the the car that I'm renting out is a
2015 Crosstrek uh about a just north of
100 000 miles on it Kelly Blue Book has
it at roughly 15 000 right now which is
private sale and so in my head
the value for this vehicle on the app
will only start to to tick downwards as
the car gets older as the miles add up
and so I'm just considering selling it
now
um getting out of Toro and just driving
uh that that 99 4Runner and then having
my wife's car and uh just going about
that so I'm just looking for some advice
yeah how much debt do you have left
I have about 30 000
um we've paid off just about 60 at this
point and all that's left to student
loans way to go right so this is going
to cut your debt in half and speed up
the process by half so how much further
let's say you sell the car how many more
months to pay off the rest of the 15.
uh I could I could probably do that
within three to four months
um just again trying to sell stuff
working odd jobs you're talking riding
around a month just at the debt even
without doing turo
right well we so we we've also had a
child so I still have that flush phone
we press pause on baby step two while my
wife is pregnant and I gave birth to our
kiddo and now she's healthy she's good
so we have extra to take it down so how
much do you have in the bank
uh just about 15. oh wow so you could
almost be completely debt free tomorrow
right I like that
now also so I'm making roughly a
thousand to 1200 a month with Toro and
so I do like the idea of keeping it
going but I could I also see just the
the quicker play of of getting
um getting rid of the car making that
money now finishing baby step two maybe
somewhat into baby step three and
um yeah so just yeah if I'm you I want
freedom faster if you want to get back
into turo and buy a cheap car just to do
that with that's on you if you want to
do that but I like the idea of in the
next 30 days you got a new baby let's be
completely debt free let's then stock up
that three to six months emergency fund
in the next three or four or five months
and now we're in a really different
place financially
yeah and you said you're a hustler so
it's like I think you're gonna get there
quick with knocking this stent out
you're gonna be able to get that
emergency fund built out and just be in
such a comfortable spot yeah and you're
willing to drive the beater Forerunner
versus the sweet Crosstrek I'm doing it
man anytime someone's willing to sell
the car even though you're not dead on
it this is going to speed up the
financial process for you through the
baby steps well just make sure you keep
a on the floor on the horizon you know
that it is a 99 4Runner you may have
something you're gonna have to upgrade
right yeah expenses on that good call
that puts the sour of the Ramsay show in
the books
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
have you been inspired to make a change
with your money want to know where to
start take our three minute money quiz
to get a plan you can follow go to
ramseysolutions.com and search for get
started to get a plan for your money
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studios this is the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm Ramsay personality George
Campbell host of the fine print entree
leadership podcast and co-host of smart
money happy hour with Rachel Cruz joined
today by best-selling author Christina
Ellis and we are pumped to take your
calls today America the number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
we want to help you take that next step
with your life with your money free
you're at a Crossroads you're feeling a
little anxious there's a lot going on in
the world Christina there's a lot to be
anxious about we want to hopefully give
you some peace yes and I love that new
ad to your to your intro the co-host of
these feels good smart money happy hour
feels good one of the top 20 podcasts in
the nation right now y'all check it out
it is amazing I haven't even listened to
the latest episode I don't usually go
back and listen to things with my voice
I don't enjoy that and uh it's proof
that I'm not a narcissist James despite
what he tweeted earlier today I'm just
kidding James was a he's a sweet
producer he would never do that I don't
even have Twitter George he doesn't even
have Twitter he's off the grid man you
can't find this guy his real name is not
James well what's crazy is you're
sitting you know you're saying there's
all this heavy stuff around money in the
world but y'all bring levity to money
which is so needed I think a lot of
people want to learn about money they
want to get better with their finances
but then they look on the news and it's
overwhelming and it's all negative and
it's all kind of depressing but you all
bring fun to money which is so needed
and so cool well we just got this
comment uh so our team just sent it over
to us it says my husband and I are
really enjoying this podcast with Rachel
and George they really bring us laughter
and we look forward to listening to them
together in the mornings we're in a
difficult season so to have something
like this to look forward to is awesome
thank you Rachel and George keep it up
and that just it warms my heart to know
that you know everyone's going through a
hard time we need to laugh laughter is
medicine and that's why I love comedy
that's why I watch late night shows
because the news is heavy and so to make
light of it a little bit while also
staying informed is very important to me
so that's how I choose to digest the
news right through the lens of comedy
and like money can be fun like we can
talk about the Royals and their money
and all the things you all unpacked this
week on the show that's right and I
learned a lot so go check it out you can
subscribe follow smart money happy hour
wherever you listen to podcasts and let
us know what you think
all right open phones triple eight eight
two five five two two five Nicole's
kicking us off this hour in Toledo
Nicole Welcome to the Ramsay show
absolutely how can Christina and I help
so I took a job and I will be relocating
between now and July of next year
and part of that relocation package was
um they're covering the sale of my home
here and all the fees they're covering
the closing costs of my new home
um they are also providing me 17 000
worth of relocation assistance
I'll get about fifteen thousand dollars
from the sale of my home and I'm a
military veteran so I get VA benefits so
I can get a 15-year mortgage with no PMI
so my question is is do I take that
thirty thousand dollars and put it
towards my sixty thousand dollars worth
of debt or do I still put it down as my
down payment on my new home oh that's a
a great question well first of all this
company is very generous that's
incredible
yeah but they're doing this you must be
very sharp what kind of work are you in
um transportation and Logistics cool
okay so you have 30 60 000 in debt
yes what's that made up of
um student loans car and uh home repair
that was done okay
and when you move do you plan on renting
for a while or what's kind of your
thoughts on housing
so I was actually planning on buying
and I'm looking to stay within 150 to
175. and what's the new area
um
it's a
Cleveland Akron area okay so you're
still in Ohio and you know the home
prices over there and how much Equity
would you be able to roll into the new
house
um between fifteen and twenty thousand
okay and that relocation money would you
need all of that or is that you can use
that towards the new house as well if
you have extra I can use that for
whatever relocation I need okay whatever
relocation assistance I need
so what's your income at the new in the
new position
monthly take home after that my military
pay and the child support is roughly 6
500 a month great so an easy way to look
at this to make a decision is to take
that and divide it by four and that will
give you a quarter of your take-home pay
and so that tells me that 1625 is my top
that's my top budget for a mortgage
payment on a 15-year fixed so how much
would you need to put down in order to
have that be the payment
so I think I looked and if I stick with
150 I would be at like 1500 a month
okay if you go out uh 150 house and how
much would you have to put down to to do
that nothing
you have zero percent
if I put nothing down I think I I think
it calculated to 1500 a month okay well
I would love for you if you have 15 from
the home sale let's put at least 10
percent down you said you're not going
to have PMI
because of the VA benefit so let's put
at least 10 percent down as the goal and
the rest we can throw at the debt
knowing that our payment is still going
to be less than a quarter of our
take-home pay which leaves you with a
lot of margin to then tackle this debt
and then roughly half in debt and half
on the down payment exactly
yeah and when you move into this new
city is this somewhere you think you're
going to want to stay for a while
yes I do okay because I mean there is
the option of taking a little bit of
time to rent we often recommend people
rent for a year when they're moving to a
new city just to even figure out the
areas make sure that you love that new
location and that job that you're not
going to want to uproot somewhere else
before you really commit to a home
purchase because that is a huge decision
and if you do need to sell that home in
the future you may not have those real
estate fees covered if you're not with
that company so there is the option to
just take a little bit of time before
purchasing to just kind of get to know
the city in the areas now you have about
what eight or nine months is that enough
time for you to actually go visit and
check out the areas and work with a real
estate agent and really start to dial
some things in
yes it is and on top of that the next
eight or nine months we're going to be
focused on knocking out this debt too
correct love it so you're going to have
uh how much debt do you think you could
pay off for the next eight months from
that 60.
um I think I can get at least 20 of it
covered wow so now we're down to 40. and
if we put 15 on that we're down to 25
and now you know by the end of next year
you'll be completely debt free with a
fully funded emergency fund
it's the goal I love it that's a great
vision to have and thank you so much for
your service and sacrifice
um and congrats on the new position and
what an amazing company thank you that's
incredible benefits that's just awesome
that is very very great so uh if if
they're hiring you know I don't want to
leave but if you're out there listening
there are companies out there offering
these amazing amazing benefits so don't
be scared to look around to start
applying if you're looking for an
increase in pay you know Ken Coleman's
talking about this all the time it's one
of the best job markets we've ever seen
so don't be shy apply that's my new
tagline Christina I like it take it if
you will hey more of your calls coming
up triple eight eight two five five two
two five this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
I'm George Campbell joined by Christina
Ellis this hour this is the Ramsay show
triple eight eight two five five two two
five you jump in we'll talk about your
life and your money John Carlo calls in
next from Puerto Rico all right
Giancarlo how you doing
I'm doing good how about you guys we're
doing wonderfully how can we help today
all right so just to give you guys
context right
um so I'm currently in baby step number
zero I'm currently getting current in
all my bills because I was about five
weeks about income and that set me back
up but I'm not too worried about that
because I should be back on track in
about three to four weeks at most good
and then baby step number one should
take me a month at most now I'm thinking
of making step number two over here in
Puerto Rico the interest rates in cars
are very high and I have around 24
000 in depth total out of which 18 000
is in my car however my car can sell for
about 14 000 with its current you know
model year
um and mileage it can sell anywhere
between fourteen to fifteen thousand but
I'll probably need to spend or lower the
price by about one to two thousand
because of physical damage repairs
mechanically everything is good but
there's a physical damage in the bumper
so I'm just wondering I've never gone
through the process of in the car and my
mindset is I'm thinking of selling it at
around 12 to 13 000 and then instead of
putting all that in the car eating about
two thousand to get um the 1000 to 2000
to get a used car and then dumping the
rest of the 10 000 and all my other debt
which should cover all of my other depth
and put around put the car down by two
thousand which would lead me to about 16
000 but that should meet me anywhere
between
um
fifteen hundred to two thousand dollars
that I could put in the car per month
and I'm wondering if that's a good idea
or how should I go about this because
like I said I've never sold a car so I'm
just looking for advice on how to go
through this process
so you're not going to be able to sell
the car as long as you have the loan on
it
okay so you're underwater on this based
on what you told me you said you have 18
000 on the car loan but it's worth 14 or
13.
correct so that means you're in the hole
by about five grand on the car right now
that's correct so that's the part of the
I didn't hear that as part of the
equation what was your solution for that
all right so what what I'm wondering
each other about this because I don't
know if I can even sell it wow I would
still oh no you can't you need a clean
title in hand and you can't have so what
you need to do uh one of two things one
which I like the best is you saving up
five thousand dollars really quickly
sell everything take on side jobs and
then once you have that five thousand
you sell it for 13 you're cleared now
you have zero dollars to your name and
no car so that's a problem
okay so you're gonna need a little more
to be able to even buy a car the other
option which this is the only time we'd
ever tell you it's okay to take on some
debt is to take a personal loan for the
difference
from a local credit union I don't know
what it's like in Puerto Rico
uh in order to cover the difference take
out a five thousand dollar loan you pay
off the debt and now we're in five
thousand dollars of debt instead of 18.
all right that sounds good and then
another question because that sounds
perfectly fine and another thing that
I'm wondering is would it also be
possible
um for me to just
um
put on hold baby step one for example so
first get Curry put on hold baby step
one if I do that in less than five
months I should have enough to make that
difference and then be able to sell that
car and continue with baby step one is
that doable or should I just wait until
I am in baby step two you would need to
wait because the problem is if you try
to skip baby step one then every little
ankle biter emergency is gonna set you
back and throw you backwards into debt
because you have no cushion so the point
of baby step one is just a tiny buffer
uh to grab those ankle biters the flat
tire the medical bill those little
things most emergencies in our lives
that we think back on are less than a
thousand dollars and so that's the
purpose of that is so that you actually
feel some traction otherwise you're
gonna be in baby step one forever
yeah all right well that sounds good to
me I think that's pretty much it yeah
and also when you go to sell that car
just make sure you really look at Kelly
Blue Book see that range you mentioned
that you've got something that you would
knock down a thousand or two dollars two
thousand dollars for but you know before
you do that in your advertising you may
want to list it at 14 or 15 like you
said and then allow that to be part of
the negotiation versus starting at 12 or
13 and then possibly having someone
complain and want a little bit more
knocked off so just make sure you really
look at the car's value and see if you
should start a little bit higher so you
have some negotiation room and on top of
a private sale John Carlo you can also
look at a lot of these online retailers
that are buying cars right now and they
are paying top dollar still so I would
take advantage of that and do your due
diligence do your homework research all
of these sites like carvana and vroom
that are paying sometimes more than you
could get private sale and you're not
dealing with the negotiations back and
forth and they're happy to go fix it up
and resell it for a profit so that's
another option for you to look into as
well absolutely and I know that this
sounds so basic but just make make sure
to clean your car before you go to sell
it having looked at used cars I've been
kind of Blown Away sometimes where I'm
like gross just vacuum the car go
through the car wash for 10 bucks and
use the free vacuums I did this the
other day to mine and it felt like I
have a brand new car yeah it's lovely
and when you're trying to sell your car
like you need that you need that like
nice car smell it like makes you more
likely to buy and it's just funny how
many people skip that very just raise it
down guys come on all right good stuff
Mary joins us up next in New York City
Mary welcome to the show
hi um thank you for taking my call um my
nerves have gotten to me oh it's just us
Mary we're gonna be fine
yeah it's fine
um so I have a question about at what
point do you start saving uh for a down
payment of a house
where are you at right now in the baby
steps
um
then you are exactly where you need to
be to start saving up we call it baby
step 3B it's an optional step because
not everyone is at you know going to buy
a house with their current state and
where they live and all those things so
that's where you do it because you have
a financial Foundation where you have no
payments and you also have a fully
funded emergency fund so that's where we
begin to save up 10 20 down is ideal to
avoid PMI
um at that point so have you looked at
houses in your area
yeah we've worked in houses in the area
and it's more so like we know that the
down payment is ridiculous at 20
um are you like in New York City proper
I yes proper yes wow so have you what
what kind of are we talking a condo
um I don't know like an actual house
area
um they have they have Sparks of like
the city that you can actually get a
house which the down payment would be
roughly two hundred thousand dollars
and so you're looking at like a million
dollar house what are we talking
that's that's the average price of any
house in New York City and what's your
income
uh
epicone combined with a wrap
sorry you broke up on us 150 sorry um
okay
all right so what's I was confused if we
should be saving for retirement at this
point too or do we stop that uh
yeah that's a great question it becomes
kind of a Choose Your Own Adventure when
you get to 3b4 some people if how old
are you two
uh I am
39. okay do you guys have anything saved
in retirement
contributing um when we first started
out at our first shop so we do have some
you know 401k and then I have a
um we both have Roth IRAs and as well as
um I should be getting a pension from my
company as well cool Matt how long do
you anticipate it'll take you to get to
that 200k
that's what I'm trying to figure out now
like we're gonna sit down and have a big
budget meeting on Saturday and kind of
gonna go over everything at that point
as to where everything lies and how long
it would take us okay because we don't
want June 3B for too long yeah we we
don't want you to pause that investing
portion for more than about two years
and so that's the purpose of it is you
get really aggressive with the savings
and the truth is you don't get to pass
on math in New York City and I'm doing
the math here on our mortgage calculator
or mgsolutions.com if you put 200 Grand
down on even a 950 house your mortgage
payment is Seven Grand
and if you're taking 12 home that is a
huge portion so it may mean you live
further out of the city it may mean it
takes you six years to save and we're
going to invest 15 while we do that
okay did I hurt your feelings Mary thank
you so much I don't want to do that
okay never I just want this house to be
a blessing and not a curse and so part
of it is you live in one of the most
expensive areas in the world and it's
just gonna take longer if that's the
goal and that's the dream so stick with
it this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
how'd you guess with health care costs
Rising learn how Christian Healthcare
Ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
have you ever noticed when you commit to
a change in one area of your life it's
easier to make progress in others we've
met thousands of people on their journey
to Building Wealth who accomplished
other amazing things along the way like
losing 50 pounds improving their
marriages finding careers they love
overcoming Stress and Anxiety
what seems impossible becomes possible
when you have a smart plan in place and
you turn up the focus and intensity on
your goals and that's exactly what we do
at our smart conference event and it's
coming to Dallas Texas on Saturday
October 22nd this is a full one day
event where we help you build momentum
in all areas of your life whether you
lost your job the credit card bill is
heating up your paychecks you need a
little pep in your step because the
financial journey is long and hard or
you're feeling all alone in this crazy
world we've got you Ramsay personalities
Rachel Cruz Dr John deloney Ken Coleman
Dave Ramsey Christina Ellis myself will
be on stage to give you a smart plan for
your money your relationships your
career personal growth you name it we'll
also have special guests Craig and Amy
grouchel there as well speaking on
marriage it's going to be a good time
and very entertaining I might add
there's going to be live music you never
know which personalities will jump up
there maybe Christina will do a solo on
the guitar
wouldn't that be entertaining more
likely John deloney because this guy
it's his childhood dream to be ripping a
solo in an arena and so we're gonna
hopefully let him do that so that's
worth the ticket price right there folks
join us live in person October 22nd get
your passes before they sell out even if
you're not from Dallas we get people who
visit us from all over the world at
these events and I love meeting them and
it's a full day it's you're you're
drinking from the from the hose on this
one I mean you just leave exhausted
motivated inspired ready to make some
changes in your life so join us bring
some friends along ramseysolutions.com
events is the place to go reserve your
seats today this is going to be a
sellout event good times you ready for
for your talk at smart conference I'm
excited yeah I'm stoked we just put on
the final touches last week and I can't
wait you're ahead of me but it's gonna
be great I'm very excited about where
it's going all right open phones this
hour triple eight eight two five five
two two five Lori joins us up next in St
Louis Lori welcome to the show
thank you thank you for taking my call
yeah how can we help
um I need to know how to plan for my
future and my children's future I am
debt free except for my mortgage but
it's I've still got quite a bit on it
um I'm in my 40s I'm a single mom I have
two Elementary School age children
um I make well 54 net but that's after
everything so about 75 gross so not a
lot
um
I do contribute 15 to my 401k I do drive
an older vehicle
I've got about a hundred thousand in
like cash on hand in different accounts
that I could access like checking
savings kind of thing
um I don't have anything set up for my
children's
education other than that that cash I
don't have any 529s or anything like
that
um so yeah I'm just looking for what's
the best way to move forward
my investments in my 401k are just
it's like a program that
invests for you automatically based on
when you're supposed to retire oh like a
Target date fund
yeah I don't I can't choose it
oh I probably can but I know nothing
about any of that so I just I just leave
it like that got it so well Lori you are
doing a lot better than you think you
are I can you sound kind of defeated and
you feel like you're not making progress
but you're amazing yeah that was my
thought you're just you're doing a
really good job I think you yeah kind of
feel heavy about it but I think we
should start with the foundation of
you're doing a really good job
so let's dig into some of these details
you've got the mortgage left what's on
that
okay that's not too bad
and you have a great income you sounded
like you you feel like you don't make
enough are you able to pay all your
bills
yeah
so the hundred thousand in cash does
that include your emergency fund
of three to six I don't have it broken
yeah I mean I definitely have my house
payments only a thousand a month awesome
Lori what's kind of your financial
background like how did you decide not
to take out debt have you been following
the baby steps what kind of got you
started on this journey and made you
want to call today
um well I've always been really
responsible with money but then I went
through a divorce that depleted me quite
significantly
um so I think there's a lot of fear that
um just because I had more so now it's
like I want to make sure that my
children are taken care of and that you
know I just I guess I've been feeling
old lately
and I just want to make sure that I have
a plan for the future
and that I'm not dependent on them I
don't want them to struggle so I think
it's a lot of it's probably fear-based
and and I've never really taken I mean I
had to pay off debt so I was intentional
at one point in my life but for most of
my life I haven't struggled financially
so I've never really been too
intentional about where my money goes
it's like if I if we go to the store I
don't have to think do I have enough to
cover it I just get it
um
so we can help with that side of it I'm
going to gift you one year of every
dollar premium to help you make a plan
for every single one of those dollars
because I think that will give you
confidence and a little pep in your step
that you're not just wandering through
your financial life and making ends meet
yeah and have you taken Financial Peace
University
no let's also get our access to that I
love it because then you're a financial
piece one year of every dollar and
there's one more thing I think I want to
gift her let's get you a copy of own
your past change your future by Dr John
deloney because you've been through a
lot and I think
um like you said you're feeling a lot of
fear I think you're feeling a bit
defeated but you're really doing a great
job and I think that you've got a really
bright future ahead but this book will
help you kind of walk through those
emotions so that you can get rid of some
of that heaviness and really take
ownership of your journey yes so Lori
we're going to do that at the end of the
call Austin will pick up we'll gift you
with all of that but before we go let me
hit you with just some real tactical
things you can do this week to make you
feel some progress number one there's
probably an advisor a financial advisor
that's attached to your 401k plan at
work so contact your HR team and figure
out who that person is so that you can
get in touch with them and they can help
you figure out what funds exist in that
account that align with our principles I
want you in growth stock mutual funds
Diversified across four types this is
you can easily find this stuff on our
website and I want you in that instead
of these Target date funds because what
those do they switch you to way more
conservative conservative Investments
over time so you're going to be invested
more in bonds than stocks and bonds have
uh they're safer bets but they also have
very little growth and I don't want that
in retirement where you go I'm running
out of money because I'm invested in
things that aren't growing that's a
problem
so that's number one I mean when I look
at my 401k that's where I get most
defeated because of course it's not done
well this year oh yeah the Market's
terrible terrible year to look at your
401k but we're thinking future Lori here
we're thinking 20 years out and so
there's a great track record on that the
second thing is opening a 529 plan or an
Esa education savings account which you
can do with one of our smartvestor pros
at ramseysolutions.com and click on
Ramsay recommends and they can help you
set one of these up and help they'll
align with our philosophy on which
mutual funds to choose inside of that
and the esa has limits of about two
thousand dollars a year but with the
money you have the hundred thousand I'd
go ahead and just fully fund that for
the year two thousand each for each of
the kids you can also do a 529 plan that
are State specific they can help you
choose one of those and those have way
higher uh limits for what you can
contribute
so that will help you benefit of that
well that money will grow tax-free and
then you can withdraw it tax-free for
Education expenses
so that will set them up for college
they're in elementary school now so you
know I think 10 15 years from now if you
just do that every year that money is
going to grow it'll be six figures and
help them go to college debt free
okay
and then anything beyond that you're
already investing 15 we're throwing some
money into the kids college beyond that
take the rest of the money in that
account beyond your three to six months
emergency fund and throw it at the
mortgage and let's start attacking that
mortgage next
okay what if I'm not sure that I'm
staying in my current home well the good
news is the money didn't disappear
because when you sell that house you
have all of that Equity that you'll be
able to roll into the next house and so
I love it because it's a four savings
plan because when it's sitting in the
bank it all of a sudden becomes the new
car fund the vacation fund instead of
the freedom fund for Lori so that she
doesn't have a house payment for the
last 25 years of her life so that's my
dream for you so start dreaming get
connected to a Smart investor take care
of the 401K you're doing great there's
just little tweaks along the way but
you're a warrior single moms are very
very impressive you're doing so great I
grew up with a single mom and y'all are
warriors amazing Heroes
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined today by
Christina Ellis and we are taking your
calls it's about your life and your
money triple eight eight two five five
two two five Colorado Springs is where
we go next Andrew joins us there what's
up Andrew
how's it going sir we are doing so great
how are you how can we help uh I'm doing
I have a question I'm on babysit
so you're breaking up on us can you
try to get to a clear spider now sir a
little better let's try that all right
so I'm on baby Step Zero okay with uh
two credit cards
and I don't know how to figure out my
debt I'm trying to figure out how to
start zero
um but I have no clue of figuring out
the how to figure out exactly what my
dad is I don't know about Avenue
do you know who you owe that debt to
um so me and the wife we've been
together for five years we know we have
two credit cards I know I went to sweat
there might be a possibility with that
company could owe some money but to just
maybe I think it was completely
negligent with money what is the fastest
way to figure out who you'll get to so
you can start paying it off well the
first place I don't think we're here son
yeah the first place I'd start with is
your credit report so you can go in on
your credit Port it's going to list the
different creditors that you owe money
to and you can pull that for free so
don't pay for it
uh so I've already made a few mistakes
okay you already paid for it
yeah I I did about six months ago but it
didn't show um
it was uh it was totally clear I believe
no I'm sorry it did show up like a 100
or 150 I'm sorry my friend you're
breaking up on us
I said it did show maybe 100 150 cell
phone bill from the past
but that's all that showed up but LS air
was I don't know if like it fully
considered me in my alliance I I I'm not
for sure
did you run a report for both of you
no ma'am I I did it on on my information
okay and you remember signing up for two
credit cards
we have two credit cards together right
now under and the total balance is like
900 we can knock that out that's no
problem it's just trying to figure out
who else might be holding the the debt
gavel
okay
how do you know that you owe the nine
hundred dollars are you getting
statements in the mail or where's that
yes they send us they sent to in the
mail and we we know we've opened these
cards
well they should you should have an
account with them can you contact them
and have them pull up your file and say
hey what what exactly do I owe have you
tried that yes sir no I I uh these two
of the 900 I fully understand I just
want to know if there's any more debt
looming over us and how to figure out
how to take care of that before we start
on baby step one
but to your knowledge these two are is
all the debt you have
you have no recollection of any other
debt sitting out there
other than that cell phone bill that it
pulled up it did ring knowledge when I
was
19.
that that I might not have paid the bill
and now they're holded me for 150 well
there'd be collectors calling you you'd
be getting some stuff in the mail so I
don't think it's going to be much of a
secret if you owe money
well and could you call up that cell
phone company just to check
yeah yes I can I haven't yet we we've
just started on this journey for about a
month now less than a month okay so
we're glad you've you're on board
and part of this plan Andrew is starting
to be very proactive with money instead
of reactive we've got to start paying
attention we're not going to be passive
we're just going to be aggressive we're
going to be on the phones figuring out
who we are what we owe how are we going
to pay this off how quickly can we do it
how can we get a financial Foundation
under us so that we can sleep better at
night and we have freedom and so we can
help you with that part with a budget
and I'll gift you one year of every
dollar premium and Financial Peace
University for you and your wife to go
through uh since you're new listeners I
want you to get a full picture of what
this crazy plan looks like so that you
can feel that motivation and progress
yeah and don't be afraid don't be afraid
to get on the phone and just call people
I think there's there's no harm in
picking up the phone and just being kind
of Shameless like if you think there's
any chance that you owe somebody
something check like so a lot of people
have medical debt that pops up they
didn't realize that they had and then
one day it just they're getting a call
from a collector and they're like whoa I
didn't see this coming so if there's any
chance you have a medical debt a traffic
ticket that's outstanding or anything
like that just give the person a call
and double check you know just to make
sure and Andrew both of you your wife
and yourself go to
annualcreditreport.com you can pull for
free once a year your credit reports
from all three credit bureaus TransUnion
Equifax and Experian and so what you can
do then is cross check between all three
to figure out what debt is sitting out
there and what you owe and that will
help you gain some confidence and
clarity
as far as you know is it just the 900
that you all owe
um well plus 150 for the public cell
phone that I do remember so Bill got a
grand call it a thousand what's your
income
uh 70 000 I just got promoted so I'm
making seventy thousand a year great so
this debt's gonna be gone tomorrow
uh I just want to make sure I because I
don't want to get caught in trap of oh
well now you didn't take care of zero so
guess what you moved up but now you got
to go back there you want to make sure
you pay your balance you've talked about
it I want everything kosher before even
moving up I want it done so I don't have
to deal with it we'll get it and write
it anytime you pay say I want this
written if this is settled in full
and close the account
well and also I would encourage you to
get that thousand dollar emergency fund
because we've got the baby steps and
baby step one you said you're on zero
baby step one is get that thousand
dollar emergency fund so I would do that
even before you worry about these cards
and then go to baby step two so that you
can avoid going into any further debt
understood I'll definitely do that but I
love this thing I did miss is I'm sorry
man no go ahead
uh something I didn't miss is the name
of that website I was trying to write it
down but I didn't annualcreditreport.com
report okay and don't pay a dollar
yeah well I already messed up but it
won't happen again that's all right hey
I think you got to cut yourself some
slack you keep saying you know you
messed up I gotta have everything right
and everything's perfect like it's a
journey it's a financial Journey we make
mistakes all the time even in our own
Journeys I think Dave would say the same
thing it's just something where you that
means you're over 12 years old if you
made a money mistake so join the club
Andrew that's it it's great so hang on
the line Austin is going to pick up
we're going to gift you one year of
Financial Peace University watch all
nine lessons you don't have to do it all
in one night but spread it out maybe
once a week There's discussion questions
along there
um some fill in the blanks to keep you
engaged as well as every dollar premium
what I want you to do is this weekend
sit down with your wife
and you're going to map out your income
for the month and that's going to sit at
the top beyond that is your expenses
list every single thing out that has hit
your bank account every transaction
needs a home in your budget and what's
going to happen at first is you're going
to be disgusted and you're going to go
we spent eight hundred dollars eating
out this month oh my goodness ouch no
wonder we don't know where our money's
going and so this is Step One is
admitting you have a problem and that's
okay I did the same thing when I first
started doing a budget
yep step two is to go all right we're
going to try to aim for 400 for our
total food budget and we're not going to
eat out because we are in debt the house
is on fire we've got to do some things
differently so then your goal is to
track every transaction with every
dollar premium it'll connect to your
bank you can drag the transactions up
and track all of those and your goal is
to stay within those parameters for each
category and when you do that you're
going to see so much progress and you're
going to feel so confident about the
future and the sacrifice goes from
difficult to addicting because you're
like where else could we save we're
paying too much for K you know what cut
the cable we got 400 bucks in cell phone
bill oh my goodness no we're switching
we're gonna go 30 bucks for the
unlimited plan we're switching carriers
we're getting ripped off right and so
you do that in every single budget line
item and it's amazing all of the money
you'll find in the proverbial couch
cushion yup but again show yourself
Grace in that process don't try the
budget for a month and go man I suck at
this I didn't hit all my line items and
and I just must not be good at budgeting
because it takes the average person
about three months to really get the
hang of it so give yourself Grace that
first few months because you will reach
that spot where you're like oh this is
exciting and it's fun but you got to
kind of you have to walk through those
periods of time where it's like oh this
isn't very fun because I gotta learn it
and I gotta get used to it you're
walking in the mirror and you're like oh
my gosh I haven't worked out in a long
time financially speaking right and it's
not fun to look at but then you see the
progress day after day month after month
and all of a sudden you got a pile of
money in the bank and no payments and
you're able to breathe and you have
margin and you can focus on your kids in
your marriage because you're not hoping
that next paycheck comes in so thanks so
much for the call Andrew glad you're
joining our weird Club Austin's gonna
pick up and help you out that puts this
hour of the Ramsay show in the books my
thanks to my co-host Christina Ellis all
the folks in the booth Austin Ben James
Andrew Zack and you America thanks for
listening we'll be back with you before
you know it
foreign
[Music]
do you love a good day Brandt want to
see the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsey Show Channel
on YouTube
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios this is the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm George Campbell joined by
Christina Ellis this hour this is your
show America so call us up
888-825-5225 that's triple eight eight
two five five two two five reminder for
those of you that enjoy the show if
you've ever found it helpful we need you
to do us a favor and go subscribe and
follow wherever you're listening leave
us a five-star review share it with a
friend we want to help and impact more
people like you and that makes a huge
difference we can't do this without you
we appreciate that and kicks us off this
hour in Green Bay Wisconsin and welcome
to the show
hi thanks for having me on sure how can
we help
well me and my husband are on we have
four five and six and I'm struggling
with we're struggling with trying to
find Focus for steps five and six right
now we're paying an extra 500 a month on
our house which will get us done with
the mortgage in about five years
um but we're we haven't checked the the
kids college off yet like we're doing a
little bit and now I'm we're just I'm
trying to do the math and figure out how
we can do it and still make progress on
our house because it feels so good to
have an end an end in sight for the
house and the kids are seven and two and
that just seems so far away but I just
feels overwhelming to to save that much
money for them to have college paid for
so I'm just looking for tips and advice
on how to do that yeah that's a great
question and balancing 456 can feel
difficult because you're not sure how
much to put towards one thing it's a
little bit squishy there's no parameters
of you have to put this amount like we
say with investing and that's it's
because every situation is different and
so in your case you do have a lot of
time but that means it's a great time to
invest for them because that money has
so much time to grow and compound right
so right I I think the balance is
working with a smart investor Pro and
doing the math and going all right
Juniors two in 16 years probably going
off to college so how can we make sure
we have a big pile of money in 16 years
that may look like two thousand dollars
a year for the next 16 years and let
that compound to close to six figures
well and just getting started in general
I think is going to be good even if it's
25 a month for each kid just that's
that's literally what we're doing our
two-year-old is getting 25 a month and
our seven-year-old is like a hundred
dollars a month and
um now I'm just trying to figure out
yeah what what where to do how do we get
to that like I'm just trying to get like
a hundred thousand dollars in there by
the time they're both 18. and is it bad
to like for the two-year-old it wouldn't
it takes like 200 a month to get pretty
darn close to that
um and then our seven-year-old is it bad
to just do lump try like we should be
able to get some lump sums with my
summer gig
I don't know well I think is it better
to do monthly or lump sum think about
this and let's say it takes six years
instead of five because we're investing
a little more for the kids
well six years from now the kids are
going to be 8 and 13.
and you have no payments in the world
and so you have all of your income at
your disposal to then save up and be
able to help cash flow College
and so the fact you're even struggling
with this tells me you're in a good spot
what's that okay is that okay to keep
paying off that like because I could
take that 5 under the extra month that
we're paying on the house and put that
towards the kids college but it feels so
good to do that extra money on the house
yes because there's an end in sight
that's a lot closer with the house
payment and you free up a payment saving
for college you're never freeing up any
payment like you are right there right
well and it's I love that you want to
help your kids with college but it's
also not an obligation you know that is
a gift and it's a wonderful thing to do
but it is still important for you all to
take care of your finances and be in a
great spot when you hit retirement age
so I definitely think you can do both in
this situation I think you guys are in a
great spot to be able to pay off the
house and even if there's a little bit
left at you know where you don't quite
have enough saved up for the kids
college I think you'll be able to cash
flow quite a bit of it but there's also
scholarships there's also picking an
affordable school there's a lot of
different ways that they can still go
debt free but I think you're on the
right track to accomplish both goals
what's your income household
um 74 000. okay and I imagine that
income will go up over time
so that's only going to help the
situation but when I'm looking at the
numbers I go okay 500 a month at the
house that's six grand a year
yeah extra what if we could fully fund
an Esa for both kids that's four grand a
year
so now we're talking we need to find 10
grand worth of margin every year in
order to keep up with both of these
goals
is that reasonable
yeah that's reasonable I think that will
give you some peace and confidence that
you're on the right track and you're not
doing too much in one and not enough in
the other just set a goal in each area
find that 10 grand in margin and make
sure you're hitting that and if you can
do extra on top of that that's only
going to help both and if you want to
put that on the house for now that's
great and then we can be more aggressive
once the house is paid off and really
ramp up the college savings
oh okay all right well that makes me
feel a lot better that's what we're here
to do just make you feel a little bit
better and thank you so much for the
call you're doing so great I just want
to encourage you in that you're in a
great spot Cameron joins us up next in
DC Cameron welcome to the show
hello I'm glad to be here absolutely
what's your question
yes I just wanted to know what are some
strategies that I can use to become more
financially independent
well tell us a little bit more about
your situation right now
okay so I recently graduated college
with my Master's in Business
Administration and I graduated in August
of 2021 and I've worked from then up
until now
and I've been able to save a good amount
of money that I'm planning to use for a
down payment for a condo or a townhouse
in my area and I just started a new job
and that's where I'm at right now what's
your income you're not
it's 55 000 a year okay and how much
debt do you have
um fortunate that I was able to graduate
with no debt awesome job so no debt and
do you have a you have a pile of money
how much money do you have in the bank
liquid cash
I have about ten thousand dollars okay
and that would be considered your
emergency fund is that about three to
six months of expenses
yes well I live at home with my mom now
so yes I consider that well let's call
that 10 grand your emergency fund
because we know you're not going to be
living there you know in the next few
years potentially yeah so any money
beyond that ten thousand now we can
start to use to invest wisely to save up
for that down payment and it sounds like
your next goal is to get in in a condo
or house or buy some property
yes
and if you're going to do that the way
to do it is to save up a big down
payment and culture will tell you hey
put as little down as possible and it'll
be okay the problem is it's really hard
to be financially independent when you
have a giant pile of debt hand hanging
around your neck
right and you know what it's like to
live debt free you don't have payments
which means all of your income stays
with you so the more you can use that
wisely to stock up a whole bunch of cash
to get property to then pay that
property off that is the path to
financial Independence and you've done
such a good job so far the fact that you
got an MBA with zero debt that's a great
accomplishment so I encourage you to
keep that debt free mindset going
forward because a lot of people get that
great job and they're like let's buy a
house let's buy too much but keep that
mindset you're doing a great job yeah
keep living with your parents for
another year stack up a whole bunch of
cash and maybe you'll have a down
payment and then I want you investing 15
of your income and that's the key
culture will tell you Financial
Independence looks a lot different but
the baby steps is the best path to do it
so make sure you're following those
steps don't waver don't fall for a tick
tock real estate investing scheme stay
the course my man this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
have you ever wanted to hear the most
popular calls from the Ramsey Show in
one place do you love a good Dave Brandt
can you tell these questions are
rhetorical well if you want to hear our
current take on events you want to hear
the best debt-free screams that people
love the most the most hilarious calls
you gotta go check out a new limited
series we released called The Best of
the Ramsay show where you get all of
those things you want and more and in
true Ramsay fashion we hit on the
current real estate market investing the
trends how to take control of your life
and money in these crazy times so you
can find all those special episodes on
our Ramsay Show YouTube channels or on
Spotify all you need to do is search for
the best of the Ramsay show you will not
regret it I love seeing the comments on
these our team did a great job just
compiling all of the best the creme de
La Creme if you will Zach's in there
he's part of our YouTube Team he's
thanking me because they love a good
shout out they really and they deserve
it you know we do very little compared
to those guys salt of the earth folks
yeah all right let's get back to the
phones the number to call is triple
825-5225 Chris is up next in Colorado
Springs Chris welcome to the show
oh thank you absolutely what's going on
well Terry and I move every like three
two to three years and we just moved to
Colorado Springs and purchased a home
it's our second home to ever purchase we
sold our other one and I I've been
working I've done most of the baby steps
not realizing until I started
researching once I got out here
um and I have no debt other than my
mortgage would y'all recommend that I
just try to pay that down as much as I
can before I go to sell and move and say
two and a half years
I am always a fan of paying down the
mortgage because it's a forced Savings
Plan
do you guys have any other goals any
other Financial expenses coming up that
you're worried about
no uh both our vehicles are newer
they're paid off
um nothing crazy or anything like that
we have two children and like like I
said we don't have any other debt other
than the house
so I'm just trying to figure out what I
should do next because I'm and I have a
401k plus my military retirement when I
get to 20 years I only have five more
years back to retire wow
um and so that would also be my income
whenever I retire
um how cool would it be to retire with
no mortgage payment and you can if
you're moving you can roll that equity
and into the next house with cash
so that y'all would recommend that I pay
down more on the house as much as
possible every month until I get out of
here because I looked into refining
someone I moved out here I didn't have
the money to put down or I had to scrape
money together to put down because the
house was so expensive and I had two VA
loans but now I have money from the
previous house to put into it but they
won't the only thing I can do is
refinance because it's a VA loan but the
interest rates are so high right now
compared to what I got when I got the
house yeah what's left on the mortgage
about 4 14. wow 414 000. big one what's
the monthly payment on that
uh 26.63 and what's your take-home pay
um I make uh 6448 a month and that's
total household income
yes my wife's a stay-at-home mother okay
yeah I mean that's a big chunkier
take-home pay just go into that mortgage
yeah and that's your I actually
contacted one of y'all's uh uh refinance
people about it and they looked into it
and they said well you can't do anything
right now your only option is refinance
but you have to wait uh and you said uh
100 or 210 days before I could do
anything but the mortgage rate it would
be so much higher than what I already
have refinancing is not the problem the
problem is you guys got too much house
well that I mean for what we needed for
the for our family and stuff
um because I'm big about my family being
comfortable wherever I go because you
know they have to follow me around for
my career so uh and the problem is the
housing market here in Colorado explains
the thing how does this payment feel
right now in your budget do you all feel
pretty strapped I know you called asking
about paying it off early but are you
guys able to afford the
2663 right now
yeah I mean we can afford it because we
have no other debt and stuff and then on
top of that the military so on top of my
like in my pay I get 2100 a month for
house payments is that included in the
6448 you mentioned yes that is included
but it's tax-free
okay well the problem I'm seeing is you
have over 40 percent of your take-home
pay
going to this mortgage and so you don't
have a lot of margin to even pay it down
early
yeah you're lucky to cover all the bills
and put food on the table and cover
insurance and all the other pieces for
your family
so I mean when do you plan on moving we
don't really
uh well I got here about six months ago
so two and a half years I'll be uh after
orders again out of here do you have any
way to increase your household income
I'm looking into trying to go to uh
officer program
okay in my last few years up that would
be like a 300 pay bump if I get accepted
into that and do you think your wife
would work outside the home at any point
well we looked into like what it would
cost for child care and her working and
stuff and it's just it financially makes
more sense for her to stay at home and
take care of the kids and with my work
schedule and everything
you said that you'll be out of active
duty in about five years what is your
plan for your next um your next stop are
you going to buy another house or or
what's kind of your vision yeah well in
two and a half years I'll move again I'm
not sure where and then in five years
I'll hit my 20-year Mark so I could
retire depending on promotions if I get
promoted I can stay in over 20 which is
the goal is to keep going as long as
possible to build up my retirement from
the military because I'm in what they
call the high three system so it's the
last three years of my take on pay they
average that out I get 50 at 20 years
and then it keeps going up a percentage
every year after that
okay when you when you move to your next
location
um do you so you plan on buying a house
then and then do you plan on staying in
that location or possibly moving after
that
it really depends on where they moved me
to uh because we've talked about moving
back because we're originally from
Tennessee uh but we haven't lived there
in over 15 years so we don't know if we
want to move back there or if we want to
settle down wherever we get sent
actually they send me to California I'm
definitely not retiring there I would
just make sure you know as you're doing
these moves and buying houses just to
look at all the fees associated with it
you know especially the real estate fees
that's going to be a decent percentage
in each transaction so you know total up
what the closing costs are going to be
what the real estate fees are and then
divide it out and see you know what is
that costing you if you are only going
to be there for three years like is that
really going to be a benefit in the long
run
and it may be worth renting in those
scenarios for a while
the problem is The Brokerage company I
went through they didn't really
explained they were like oh well you'll
just be able to because our last home we
had built and we made it over 150 000 on
it so once I pay like scraped together
the money for a down payment on this
house I re replenish my
um like my savings account and
everything
um so what's this house
this house is worth uh five five uh 520
I think right now so you put about 100
down on it and the rest went to savings
yeah and once I got and sold the other
house a couple months later because we
had to eat that house for a couple
months the market cooled down well right
now you're gonna have to maintain where
you're at and I would pay it down so
that when you move into that next house
the payment is very reasonable I want
you on a 15-year conventional mortgage
where the payments no more than a
quarter of your take-home pay that's
what's going to give you the margin and
right now you're talking about you want
your family to be comfortable but the
problem is it's hard to be comfortable
when almost half your paycheck is going
to the mortgage
yeah and that that's where I'm at I went
I wish I started listening to you guys
sooner my last Duty station uh was
training recruits and I didn't exactly
have time to focus on finances and stuff
well hey thank you so much for your
service and thank you for your
willingness to move around like that to
take your family and uproot them and
move through all these different cities
to serve our country that absolutely
that means a lot thank you and Christina
a lot of these uh areas where the
military's folks are based the
neighborhoods and Dave's talked about
this on air because of how much people
are going and coming the house prices
don't appreciate all that much and so
it's not a great investment in those
areas because there's always inventory
and supply and demand is how the how the
housing market works as we've seen the
last few years and so this can be a very
dangerous scenario for folks that are
not there for long periods of time they
take on too much house they have very
little equity and so I just want Chris
to have more Equity more margin in his
life and to be able to retire with
dignity with no house payment instead of
continually staying in the cycle
absolutely well he's in Colorado Springs
so hopefully when he sells this house
he'll get a nice real estate market for
sure over there yeah but we're glad you
found us we glad we're glad you're on
board with us now and can use us moving
forward thanks for the call Chris triple
eight eight two five five two two five
you call in we'll talk about your life
and your money this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
to the Ramsey Show I'm George Campbell
joined by Christina Ellis this hour the
number to call is triple eight eight two
five five two two five on occasion we
get some really nice guests in our lobby
that travel from all over the country
sometimes the world just to come see us
at the headquarters here so I want to
encourage you to do so we've got free
baked goods free coffee people don't
know this but they were asking about my
Ramsey show mug and I went like hey you
got to visit us to get it it's free one
per family if you come see us so uh
that's a that's a hot ticket item but
occasionally in the lobby there's a
question that we put on air and so on
the debt free stage we have David from
Corpus Christi who has a question for us
how's it going David hey great uh thanks
for thanks for having me uh thanks for
your time I appreciate it absolutely
what's going on uh yeah we're about a
year ago I uh I moved from Florida and I
sold my house in Florida and we made out
pretty well with the with the equity in
the house
um and then some complications with
closing in Florida and then closing in
um in our new house we had to we got
delayed in Florida uh had to take a VA
loan for the Texas house so we weren't
able to put in all the money that we had
into the new house uh you didn't have
the funds in time for closing exactly
yeah
um so now we have a hundred thousand
dollars sitting in our bank account and
um some things we've done with it was uh
we set up a 529 for our little girl uh
done Ira contributions for the year and
now we're now we're sitting at a hundred
thousand we're on uh four five and six
and uh just looking so you guys have to
well let's say you did have those funds
before closing would you have put them
into the house that was the plan yep
um I would have done uh done the 15 year
um but unfortunately we uh we went with
a 30 year that's all right well we can
still pay this thing off aggressively
and what's on the mortgage what's left
uh we got about 350 left okay would it
feel good to knock it down to 250
tomorrow
see that's uh that's a question because
it wouldn't really lower our monthly
payment and we're you know kind of
hurting a lot right now with the with
inflation
um but yeah it would feel good
eventually to is this outside of your
emergency fund yes sir okay so you have
100 gram of liquid cash that you can do
what you want but you're saying you feel
it feels safer to just have it sitting
in the bank I don't want it sitting in
the bank because it's not working for me
um so I'm thinking like maybe doing a
brokerage account and trying to get a
little bit more uh return because I have
a two and a half percent interest uh and
if I refinance now then it's going to be
you know close to five or or whatever
what's the interest rate on your
mortgage uh it's two and a half okay
well um I mean you're in 456 you're
doing 15 to retirement you've got the
kids college underway the next step is
to pay down the house and I know it
doesn't lower your payment to put that
100 Grand but it does you know cut it by
a third and so I would still do that if
I were you okay I know it's hard
mentally because on paper you're like I
can make this in the market and why
would I put a brokerage account yeah
well we're seeing what the Market's
doing you put that 100 Grand in a
brokerage account and in three months it
could turn into 80. and now you're going
oh my gosh versus the fourth savings
plan of the house because I don't know
about you I'm human which means I'm
fallible which means that 100 Grand can
easily turn into you know what we kind
of deserve that newer car safer for the
kids got to get the nice Honda Odyssey
Minivan let's get the 2020. and so it
turns into a lot of other things and so
I love putting it into the house as a
way to force myself into debt Freedom
okay
what do you think Christina well and
just keeping that vision of what it's
going to feel like when you have a paid
off house like I think right now it's
like oh man I'm still going to make the
same payment every month and that money
is just not going to be liquid anymore
but it's like how much quicker can you
get to that spot where you have zero
payments in the world and how good will
that feel how secure will you feel
especially now with inflation and so
much gloom and doom in the markets and
in the news but it's like if you got a
paid off house you're just going to be
sitting back chilling and so keeping
that vision in mind where it's not that
immediate gratification of feeling like
a lower payment but it's that long-term
goal of gosh it's gonna feel good how
old are you uh 30 30. that's awesome so
do you guys have a vision for when you
want this house paid off
um well kind of similar to the last
caller I'll only be here for another
maybe two years
um so probably won't pay this one off
but but you're gonna be on this Earth a
lot longer yeah exactly okay um but two
years in the house you're gonna have
that money to roll into the next one and
that's where that four savings plan
comes into play because you roll into
the next one today and you're like well
we're still gonna have a giant mortgage
hanging over our heads yeah for 15 or 30
years and you know I grew up thinking
you just have a mortgage until you
retire and die like that's just part of
it it's the it's the American dream and
we paid off our mortgage last December
uh famously on that stage and it's 32
and my wife was 31 and let me tell you
there's nothing like it and uh I meet
very few people who pay off their house
and regret it and go you know what I'd
rather have that 250 in the bank making
me feel good uh there's nothing like
having no mortgage payment so what is
your mortgage payment today it's uh it's
about 2300 a month yeah and so I just
put that on paper and go what is 2300 a
month every year here and what is that
over 10 years if I can invest that kind
of money and what could I how could we
send our kids to college completely debt
free and not worry about it how could we
retire early at you know 45 or 50. if we
don't have a mortgage payment for the
next 20 years and so I want you to maybe
sit down with your wife on a dream day
and start dreaming about it pray about
it and go what's our vision for the next
10 years yeah not tomorrow not what's
going to happen in the next month with
the economy and inflation think further
out than that okay because this is going
to be a blip on the radar of your entire
life as you watch your little girl grow
up and I'd love her for her to grow up
in a home that's paid for that's a cool
Vision that's the dream yeah I left 10
years we'd like to have it paid off
awesome well and keep watching the debt
free screams because even sitting behind
the desk and listening to them man it
just puts fire in your belly when you
see people who are doing it and they
paid it off like you said you had that
feeling at 31.32 of complete Freedom
moving forward and it's like just keep
watching them to keep that motivation
and keep that vision and that why right
in front of you I listen to you guys
every day appreciate it man well thanks
for visiting us thank you so much for
the question really really appreciate
the time thank you thank you for your
service it's awesome all right we're
gonna move on to the phones uh where I
can't see them unfortunately
um Kelly's there in Jackson Mississippi
Kelly how are you
I'm great how are y'all we're doing
fantastic how can we help today
hey thanks so much for taking my call my
question is
the overview is should I changed my
attack income tax withholding
to keep more in my paycheck so that
nothing is taken out and then just allow
for that in a sinking fund in our budget
and why would you do that
well okay so where are we are
we will be debt free by February I'd
like to accelerate that a little more
um so we're on baby step two I have the
thousand dollar emergency fund and I'm
trying to get as much into my into
paying off that debt as possible
and then
um after that I just think it'd be a
good practice for me to keep that money
as long as possible to you have to pay
the check at the end of the year
well Kelly I know you want to accelerate
the debt but what you're doing is it
you're creating the fastest path to
owing the IRS a giant chunk of money and
that's a scary place to be my friend
because you're robbing Peter to pay Paul
you're not really helping your debt-free
journey because that 50 bucks that you
get back in your check is now 50 bucks
you have to then go save in a savings
account to have the money come tax time
you see what I'm saying right okay well
I mean we would make room for it in our
just our monthly budget well you know
the the best laid plans of mice and men
uh it's one of those where you're like
yeah no no we'll save for it later we
got that later but then later never
comes and all of a sudden you go to file
your tax return and I tell you this out
of experience Kelly because I've been
there where we're like we have six
thousand dollars to the IRS and now it
becomes an emergency when it didn't have
to be and now you're robbing your
emergency fund if you even have it uh or
you're getting on a payment plan with
the IRS which is frightening and so I
want you to get to zero I want you to
not get a refund and not owe money the
closest you can get to zero the better
I got you yeah the IRS is not a
forgiving debtor that is not someone you
want we put it at the top of the debt
snowball anytime anyone has IRS debt and
I just I I want bigger things for you
than to be owing the IRS every year or
some kind of scheme
there's no way around it you got to pay
the tax man so I would adjust your
withholdings to try to get to exactly
zero you can do the math there's a tax
withholding calculator on the IRS
website where you can pop in all your
numbers and it'll show you exactly how
much you need to put away every month in
taxes from your paycheck so that's what
I would do I know you want to accelerate
the debt free Journey but the only way
to do that is to create more income and
to shave more expenses that is the true
path and that comes down to doing a
budget every single month
thanks so much for the call this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Peter 3 8. finally all of you be
like-minded be sympathetic love one
another be compassionate and humble
Maya Angelou said my mission in life is
not merely to survive but to thrive and
to do so with some passion some
compassion some humor and some style oh
love that love that from Maya good stuff
that's awesome all right to the phones
we go Javier joins us in Phoenix welcome
to the show my friend how you doing
I'm good thank you for taking my call
yeah what's going on
I will
me and my wife
first and we started snowballing our our
debt but uh the question is should I put
that on hold and just try to focus on
just losing more money um I had a drunk
driver crash into my house about two
weeks ago oh my goodness yeah total God
told him my wife's vehicle so instead of
having the two because we're down to one
luckily for her she works from home but
we still have to get the kids to school
and then back from while I'm at work so
no one was injured no one was injured
thank God yeah there was no fire in the
house no water damage it's just
basically like unless you want to call
it cosmetic he came straight Burling
through the front door pretty much oh
wow that's scary and it damaged your
wife's vehicle
the damage so it was a total loss of my
wife's vehicle and um so what we got I
mean it was nothing brand new we had a
2012 uh Hyundai Tucson and with my fault
because the driver who crashed Insurance
didn't have no insurance so basically
all on our insurance luckily we have
full coverage so you know we we got it
paid out
Seven Grand after deductibles
um so should I put on hold trying to
rebuild uh our thousand dollar uh
emergency fund and the snowball debt to
try to make up the difference to get
something close to that same year and
model
how much is it to replace the car you
said they gave you seven thousand how
much would it be together
[Music]
uh well we had to sit down so we're
trying to find a crossover you know like
to just kind of plunge everything
because more than likely once they start
construction on the home we're gonna
have to leave
and it's just basically uh depending on
where we go uh we might have to be
taking the dogs back and forth uh to
either my sisters or my father-in-law's
house so I need something big enough to
like get the dogs in there okay how much
money do you have in the bank right now
aside from the 70s
uh apart from the 7000 I probably got
maybe like 500 and and my little site
account that I have for savings and how
much debt do you all have
um well we just have the house and we
have Maybe One credit card that's
probably like about
um about 2500
okay so that would be the only thing in
your debt snowball is that credit card
yeah and then we'd be moving on to two
credit cards but that's like the total
amount and we're almost done with the
smaller one okay and then what's your
income
uh my income I want to say I make about
uh
30 000 a year and then my wife is
probably just under me so she's probably
like maybe 36 38 so about 75 grand a
year gross income for both of you yes
okay so how quickly can we save up
another few grand and get a vehicle
um but it's only one day a week but I
mean it is a full eight hour hour shift
that I'm getting on there okay on top of
my Monday through Friday and then she's
just Monday through Friday so if you've
got 7 500 to your name I'm gonna put
away 1 000 of that for the starter
emergency fund which leaves you 6 500
and that becomes the car fund and we are
going to get a car like next month and
if it's not the dream car that's okay we
can always upgrade later and sell that
one and upgrade to the bigger one right
now it we can't be super picky
yeah and you're going to be in a very
different place to my wife and age I and
my wife doesn't get it she's like I will
need something we're not getting
anything older we need the same year and
I'm just like I just can't get through
to her on that part so mentally she's
stuck on she wants that exact car and
now that car is 10 grand instead of
seven
yes exactly yeah so let's see can we
save up two grand in the next month and
just sell as much as we can work as much
as we can extra shave our expenses as
much as we can so that we can expedite
this process get that vehicle then we're
going to focus on getting back to the
debt paying off the 2500 cut up the
cards we're closing them we're not going
to use them anymore as an emergency fund
and then we're going to focus on getting
a fully funded emergency fund in place
so we never have to deal with this kind
of stress again yes yes I that's what
exactly I need to do but it's just weird
because I feel like sometimes like she
doesn't see my point of view and I tell
her like well Dave Ramsey she's like I
don't want to hear about the Dave Rams
well that's yeah that's not going to get
you get you where you want to go well
and I think it's important to just
acknowledge that she's probably grieving
this like this wasn't just like her car
this was a big deal somebody came onto
her property and wrecked and she lost a
car that was you know she liked she was
happy with that car and so this is a lot
to process for her so I think just
giving her space space and time to
grieve a bit while also making the right
financial decisions could be helpful
just acknowledging just how big of an
emotional thing that is to overcome I
think the numbers I think what George
said is great you're you can find a big
vehicle for sixty five hundred dollars I
mean it's not going to be the most
glamorous vehicle it may be an 0-9
instead of the 2012. okay yeah but it's
both and it's it's doing the right
financial decision but also giving her
space to grieve and acknowledge those
emotions and kind of work through and
process because having what y'all went
through happened where it affected your
house it affected your car that's a huge
deal yeah and we're going to gift you
one year of Financial Peace University I
want you and your wife to sit down
together watch all nine lessons I think
that will get you on the same page and
it will turn Dave's name from a cuss
word into a happy name yeah that's what
we want for you guys so hang on the line
Austin will pick up we'll gift you that
Financial Peace University thank you
well it'll help you see the future too
because right now it's like this moment
is so heavy but going through financial
peace you're going to be able to see the
why of the 6500 car right get a bigger
picture yeah that's good all right
Ashton joins us up next in Springfield
Missouri Ashton welcome to the show
hey guys to uh just say God bless you
both
um it's uh it's an honor oh thank you
what's going on
so long story short I'll make this quick
I know I believe I'm one of the last
callers me and my wife
um just had the privilege to pay off all
our debt this past May and God is so
good man way to go congratulations
awesome she uh she's a mini Christina
let's just say that
we love to hear it you got driven she
got her whole entire bachelor's paid for
through a scholarship to where um I mean
it's this guy I mean God bless that
that's amazing so I was the knucklehead
and took out the student loans so I was
36 000 roughly oh me too in 17 months
that's so great hey join the party man
but it's gone now yeah let me oh yeah
let me get to the question I apologize
so now that she's in grad school she's
going to doctor of physical therapy
school and she's also getting all of
that paid for through a scholarship way
let's go
I know it it's incredible she's a part
of a Native American tribe and so
there's a lot of opportunities out there
for those that may not necessarily think
they can yeah and so I just want to put
that out there okay we got about less
than a minute what's the question we can
help with today here we go
about that so there's going to be
clinical rotations on her last year of
grad school and so that's a lot of
traveling four different locations
within nine months should I start
investing now should we pile up cash
um for that storm or should we do a
little both how old are you don't have
any housing right now I'm 25 I just
turned 25 and she's 23. okay I would say
to pile up cash for the next year and
see what life looks like you guys have
plenty of time to invest and that'll
give you guys some peace while she's in
school and we're figuring out what the
next steps look like beyond that yes we
can split the difference we can start
saving up a down payment we can use that
cash towards that we can start investing
and fully fund a Roth IRA if we're in a
good spot with a down payment depending
on the home that you're looking at and
so I think you go about this with wisdom
and we don't know what her income is
going to be either right
right right we are daily listeners so
we're all in we've been all in and so I
figured you'd say this I just wanted to
get a verification we're not surprising
around here Christina you pretty much
know what we're gonna say
I love it y'all are rock stars way to go
that's awesome I feel good about
yourself she is incredible guys I
married up for sure that's the only way
to do it my man we love to hear it well
that puts this hour of the Ramsay show
in the books my thanks to my co-host
Christina Ellis all the folks in the
booth Austin Ben James Zach and Andrew
and you America we can't do this show
without you we appreciate you listening
in until next time spend wisely save
intentionally and give generously
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
do you love a good day brand want to see
the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]